good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight if you've been watching
the other channels lately there is at
least one thing you've learned about the
caravan of Central American migrants
currently marching toward our southern
border the whole thing is no big deal
these are nice people every single one
of them much better people than you are
they have the deep moral authority that
comes from living in a third world
country unlike you mister pampered
suburbanite they're not invaders they
are future model Americans there is
nothing at all to worry about
we're told well that's been the chorus
from politicians and news anchors who
think they're politicians for weeks and
weeks now if you have any concern at all
about this Caravan you are a bad person
in fact you sir are a racist all of this
for a group of people a lot of whom are
mothers and children who pose no
imminent threat to the United States
call this an invasion it might be the
most pathetic invasion of a country in
world history if this were actually an
invasion but of course it's not is it in
sending troops to the border to deal
with a caravan that hasn't proven to be
violent
stop saying they're monsters they're
more mothers than monsters don't say it
why don't any of you say that there's
the line of the day more mothers than
monsters turns out that's not quite
right more brothers than mothers
actually according to the border patrol
the caravan is in fact about 70% single
men not families women and children but
overwhelmingly single men according to
Mexico's own ambassador many in the
group are quote very violent that's what
he recently told NPR so to restate the
caravan is in fact heavily mail and
highly dangerous when the Mexican
ambassador says that to Public Radio
what you're looking at obviously is
racism more right-winger II just kidding
what we're actually seeing is relentless
dishonesty from the very people who are
paid to inform us there is nothing to
worry about they tell us like we're
children but they don't really know that
they don't really know anything they are
wholly ignorant and yet utterly
self-confident they're good at
moralizing and white
facts so who exactly is in the caravan a
lot of them probably are what they
appear to be poor people from
disorganized countries looking for a
better life it's understandable but are
some of them gang members - how about
drug dealers or human traffickers
shut up say the news anchors don't ask
those questions but if you really cared
about America you'd want answers to
those questions you would insist on
knowing would you let your kids sleep at
a stranger's house probably not you love
your kids
our leaders ought to feel the same way
about us they don't
instead they see their own countrymen as
the real threat in the minds of the
people making our country's rules
foreigners are always superior to
Americans watch Don Lemon explain so we
have to stop demonizing people and
realize the biggest terror threat in
this country is white men most of them
radicalized
right up to the right and we have to
start doing something about them there
is no travel ban on them there is no ban
on you know they had the Muslim ban
there is no white guy ban so what do we
do about that we have to start doing
something about them Don Lemon says keep
in mind that he's talking about an
entire racial group currently living in
this country
what exactly does Don Lemon have in mind
for quote them deportation internment
camps more affirmative action it would
be good to know some of us would like to
tell our sons what's coming
we contacted CNN today to ask them what
they plan to quote start doing to this
dangerous group of racially defective
Americans they never replied maybe lemon
will be more specific about his plans on
tonight's show but without even hearing
the details it's pretty clear where the
people on TV stand they instinctively
side with foreign nationals over
American citizens every time if you're
wondering why they're far more upset
about migrant camps in Mexico than
homeless encampments in Orange County
that's why just yesterday in the New
York Times a columnist called Michelle
Goldberg noted approvingly the Democrats
can win elections in Georgia if the bad
old people who don't agree with her
agenda are displaced by a large group of
new people who do
her piece was entitled we can replace
them imagine writing something like that
about your fellow Americans imagine
running it in your newspaper they didn't
think twice because that's how they
really feel